designer dahvie Tomashevsky has called
his new collection heavenly bodies
inspired by a book about sacred tombs is
21 autumn winter outfits are a
celebration of the beauty of women
the german-polish designer is showing
his work at berlin Fashion Week for the
eighth time but the novelty has not worn
off
staff matka style I get to play a part
in shaping the fashion scene in Berlin
and Germany can do son it feels amazing
to be a part of it midwest em da Von
Doom Midcoast I think I hope to have an
important role in Germany's changing
fashion landscape in dmem un poco de
cada pasadena talvez motivate left the
designer founded his label in Berlin in
2009 and has come a long way in the
short intervening years it was a long
road to the German capital having
studied fashion in Britain art history
in Poland and working for the French
labels Sonia weekend and calm digga saw
in Tokyo he came to Berlin to visit
friends but he ended up staying on
or more that's my own bus if you want to
make fashion and do something fulfilling
you have to feel good and I feel good
here funnily enough our biggest client
base is in Berlin or in Germany we sell
more here than anywhere else mice and
that's why I'm here here and now that's
being been here yet some hotels it
didn't take long for the Gdansk born
designer to find his niche combining
stylish cuts and fine fabrics dougie
Tomashevsky describes his style as new
Couture and charges between 500 and
several thousand euros for his designs
what could you and stayed in Paris does
the haute couture comes from Paris as a
craft that dates back hundreds of years
but it doesn't really have a place in
Germany yeah I thought both in the 20s
Berlin had a booming textile industry
and that's why I have my main base here
I like the combination of great craft
and small series of clothes because we
never make more than a thousand of each
garment they're always limited editions
and Couture only exists in Paris so to
some extent I've combined the two things
thus being have is this busy limited
under foundation back to Fashion Week in
the tent at the Brandenburg Gate his 12
models are preparing for the show Dobby
Tomashevsky 'he's work has already
received several new talent awards and
he's part of a mentoring program run by
german vogue his talent is not lost on
other fashion publications either
daveniss filmic Manasa dove it stands
out in Berlin because he goes for a
luxury that we don't have here in the
gallivan and billion cool on hip in
Berlin everybody wants to be cool and
hip and in but David does his thing he
has a feeling for top quality and first
class materials I think it might have a
yard of a fine cut things like that of
all the designers here he's the
luxurious one yeah Steiner looks as baby
buddha Amma's danskin we've always been
taken very seriously and have always
received praise that makes me very happy
because it removes the fear about
whether what you're doing is right
judging by the applause Dobby
Tomashevsky has done everything just
right